oui mais avant de développer tous ses
titres cette tragique nouvelle nino
ferrer s'est donné la mort aujourd'hui
dans le lot s'il avait 64 ans cet
artiste éclectique et est devenu célèbre
grâce à des tubes qui marqueront la
période yéyé dans les années 60
savoie restera gravé dans nos esprits
richard tribaux c'est en 1966 que nino
ferrer avait commencé sa carrière de son
vrai nom agostino ferrari il avait
enchaîné des tubes aussi fantaisistes
que mémorable le téléfon bien sûr mais
aussi les cornichons et le sud
ding poésie et de nostalgie un sud où il
s'était installé après son retrait du
monde du showbiz en 1972 c'est dans
cette maison du quercy qui vivait avec
toute sa famille et ses animaux
familiers
c'est là qu'il continuait à composer
loin du stress de la ville et des
sunlights des chansons pour quelqu'un
d'autre mais j'aurais pas enlever des
chantiers - 9
parce que la célébrité je suis pas du
tout faits pour ça en fait tout en ayant
publié une vingtaine d'albums nino
ferrer avait une autre passion dans la
vie
la peinture une peinture pleine de vie
et de couleurs
elle était parfois naïve et onirique
mais là aussi l'artiste se méfier du
succès et de l'argent pour moi la
peinture c'est quelque chose de
totalement gratuit c'est quelque chose
qui m'apporte beaucoup de joie et j'ai
très peur d'eux
de lui donner un côté mercantile et d'en
avoir la vie gâchée
à 63 ans nino ferrer ne sortait plus
guère de sa maison du quercy sauf pour
se rendre parfois dans quelques galeries
de peinture
il nous laisse l'image d'un homme simple
et sincère au talent éclectique et qui
aura composé quelques chansons
inoubliables à la fois plein d'humour et
de tendresse
pourtant passé ce chien tous les dix ans